how are you moses you look cute thank
you
thank you so much i'm wearing about four
hours worth of makeup right now you look
that face did look beat
it did it did it i've been taking a hit
you look great you look like you just
cyber bullied some 12 year olds on call
of duty modern
that's what i'm about this is very
fitting for twitch
this is the look i didn't know
how weak my sauce was until i've had to
follow you
on stage boo that's so cute yeah like
i've lied to host before i'd be like oh
i have a thing just so i didn't have to
follow you because like once you get up
there it's impossible to go up there
with my [ __ ] but negra pretty poor
guys
you do a really great thing where you
you are very present
you you talk to the crowd in the moment
how much of that carried over to the
special which is something that's like
this big thing in your mind we're like
this is tape forever
i i really feel like it's still carried
over like i just really still tried to
stay in the moment
i think a person that really helped me
with that like randomly is bill burr i
had called them like
maybe four days before kind of like
freaking out you know what i mean
like on some real like nerd freaking out
stuff and i was like
can i send you like the whole thing and
can you just like listen to it and like
right
tell me if it's terrible and he was like
you don't i don't need to do that you
know what i mean like
he's just like kind of on some chill out
and he was basically he said to me
the thing that he said that stuck with
me was he said
all you're doing is marking where your
set is
at this moment in time that's a really
great way to think about it he was like
you're gonna feel like you missed things
you're gonna watch it and feel like oh i
should have said that or i
flubbed this line he's like it's just
impossible not to do that kind of stuff
but he's like all you're doing is
marking where your set is in this moment
at this
time and that's that's all it is and
once i kind of embraced that energy of
it it took a lot of that kind of weight
off of me
and allowed me to just be natural in the
way that i
am and i think it truly did help it all
yeah to be present in that moment
it's a great way to think about it like
hey listen this is where i'm at
right now and not thinking right will i
get another special after this will i be
able to tour
right right exactly you taped a special
in atlanta versus boston where you're
from
what was the thought behind that i just
didn't want to be bothered with my
family
i just felt like it was too seriously it
was just too many my grandmother had 11
kids
i grew up there my whole life i've got
tons of friends and i just didn't want
to be overwhelmed by
people i wanted to be able to focus on
the thing
i had to do yeah and just perform in a
fun
city people feel weird about talking
about people on stage
knowing that they're in the crowd like
family members like actually this is how
it happened it's like well your version
of what happened is not funny
right and no i don't i don't i think the
only person that i'm concerned about
when it comes to stuff like that
is my girlfriend because i live with her
yeah
but other than that no don't worry
about it so have you guys if you had
family members
reach out to you and be like um actually
why did you say this and you're just
like i don't care
i mean i don't ever put them in it in a
real way i have 11 cousins so i'll say
one of my cousins
now if you you the guilty party then you
just know you the guilty party you know
what i mean i'll say uh my aunt
i have seven aunts you know like i don't
ever put a name to the person you know
right you're not putting people on
blasts
no no no i don't put anyone on blast i
remember
a very specific set this is when i was
like just getting to know you i think it
was 2017 montreal which is where
comedians would be
today if this wasn't happening it's the
biggest comedy festival you were part of
the new faces
me and jack never in the balcony and it
was very rough because everyone was
bombing their new faces sets this big
opportunity you get where you basically
tell the world who you are
you get five minutes and it was rough
and people were bombing left and right
and then you got up there and you're
supposed to do like the cleanest version
of your set of like what would my
sitcom be and you just started talking
about your divorce
in a very real way and crushed harder
than i've
ever seen anyone crush on new faces set
uh incredible oh that's true what was
the thought going
before that because i only talked to you
after i talked to you before
of like was there a [ __ ] part of you
or was there
of like this is the only thing that's
gonna work right now i mean
one i was that was the set i was gonna
do that's just that i had been preparing
to do to go into new faces and like
i'm just a firm believer of like i can't
be doing [ __ ] i don't do because if i
win doing something i don't do then i'm
always gonna have to do that thing and
i'm gonna be miserable and if that's the
case and i might as well go back to
working at the john hancock meal room
so like why even why even sat down that
road
so it was kind of like i just got to
present this my way and like do it how i
do it because
that's the way if i'm going to win i
want to win you know what i mean yeah
and i felt like also
i was invited and you know what i do
like i haven't changed it up
so why would you think i would get on
stage all of a sudden now and come out
you know talking like i'm some super
clean
comic like that just didn't make sense
to me to approach it that way
right but before it was nerve-wracking
and people were being
crazy and i knew that most of those
people were gonna bomb i've never got to
say this
publicly but i really did please please
please please i knew that most of those
people were gonna bomb and not because
they weren't
good but because of the energy that was
back in that room it was
nuts everybody was on edge it was the
craziest
vibe i had ever felt and i'm like you
can't have fun
on stage like this this is insane so i
left
i left that room that they were holding
us in and i went down to the bar
and i was drinking it just like talking
to people that were like
coming in and trying to like go sit down
and stuff and i was just hanging out
treating it like a regular
thursday night at the improv because i
was like i can't be bothered with all
this craziness
and i think that helped like alleviate
my brain of all
that nut stuff like i think that's an
important thing if there's any comic
watching it's like put yourself in the
energy that works for you like don't
don't feel like you have to sit in that
madness because that's
what's insane very important that i
learned from you
and one of the only reasons i got to
talk to you in the first place was that
because we have a lot of mutual friends
so we do the same shows but you always
would talk to just anyone that's around
and i happen to be anyone right before
you go on stage so you're talking like
yourself
and i'm like so i grew up half irish
and half person yeah yeah no no one
talks like that
yeah yeah and that does help it's like i
i like that pace like i like to be in
the middle of a conversation they're
like you're next and i'm like cool
and i could just like go up and like do
my thing i like that pacing of energy
because it
it does keep me in the moment you know
have you been out to any of the the
protests
um no i i have lupus so one i just
really haven't been out much
period and not want to really be risky
out there
like that so no i haven't um but not to
say that if i didn't i necessarily would
be like i've gone to them
in the past and i just find myself uh to
be more effective in other ways
yeah as far as i think that's what a lot
of you know
people with money could do is like yeah
put your money where you're
not like insert yourself into the
conversation have you seen any white
cringe
allies online because i have seen some
i mean online is just all cringe
everything you know the whole thing is
just like
ugh like no one's asked of course i was
asking that you said
yes and also and also like
yeah for real and also like the
explanations of like
it's like white people are always
annoying with information
no matter the information they're just
like annoying
information and
and it's like just all the research that
they're newly doing and just trying to
like tell you about yourself a little
bit it's just like
annoying and there's a lot of moves that
i'm like i don't know we really
care that much about that like don't be
taking
all the flags away from the nascar
people like i get
no car could have a confederate flag but
don't tell people they can't
wear one one that helps me identify
people who i should not be around if i
did go to
the nascar rally it's very right and
very easy for me to know
no also as a black person it's
unsettling like
don't take away all the white people's
like these poor white people
need something because you take away
their confederate flag that's
you know they're lynching like just let
them hold on to a little piece of
whatever they got
and that's fine the flag is better than
murdering a human being right it's like
maybe no you can't have it over a state
capitol because that state capital
represents
everybody but if you don't want the
confederate flag to drape over his man
boobs and represent him
by all means let him do that absolutely
yeah the flag is a helpful reminder it's
a contact tracing for racism of like yes
this is a racist person stay away
yeah i don't want to get into a
conversation and learn about this person
no
i love when i see someone ride by with
the flag of their car and a gun it's
like don't drive by him
go that way good to know so as far as
like
what i mean white people are stepping
down from voice over jobs
and jemima's cancelled i mean in the
bigger picture how
helpful is that or is that a cop-out and
like oh i don't do anything else because
i did this one thing
i think it's a little above i do think
it's helpful in the sense of like
i do think it's helpful for white people
being aware of like my privilege is
getting me things that other people are
not having access to
and if i actually want to be helpful
then i need to
recognize that and then do something
about it and not just
recognize it so i do like the action
behind it but then again
like you're saying it goes too far like
we had to cancel uncle ben
and that really messed me up because one
it's all perception
i never saw him as a man servant i
thought he was the runner of a rice
company
he had a suit on i was like oh this is a
distinguished
black man that made good rice like i
really never
put the other stank on it with that and
i was proud to eat uncle ben's i'm like
look at me supporting this
batman and his good rice but yeah
apparently it was
it was some white people rice right well
i think it's for white people it's like
well
now i don't have to do the really
uncomfortable thing that's why i'm like
standing up for black people in my life
because i did this one thing of this
thing has nothing to do with
rice that white people don't even eat
uncle ben has too much seasoning
right that's what i i always felt like
it was the black rice and i had all like
the black stuff in my home we had uncle
beds we had
if it had a black face on it we would
buy it and that was probably
the white man's propaganda but i did
like having a black man on my race
it's comforting so i think yes it's a
sure white people should not play people
that are not
people of color in voiceover but i don't
even know about that i don't 100 agree
with that
i just think we're at a time where these
things need to be shifted and so they're
shifting yeah but i hope we get to a
time where like people could just be
doing what they want you know like
i think that's the ultimate goal like i
don't i don't think it should be a thing
like i was talking to alex english
and he was like well i'm tired of
straight actors playing gay actors i'm
like why can't there's acting
you know i mean i was like i think the
problem is there's not enough roles and
gay people aren't getting roles and so
it's frustrating
and then you see a straight actor
playing role and you're frustrated but i
would like to see
gay actors play straight actors or
straight out like because it's
that's the art form and a part of why
you want to act is to
be something that you are not and
portray something that is not
necessarily
you so we got all the white people just
being white and all the black people
just being black and all the gay people
in their actual life and we don't really
need to see them
portray or project anything else you
know so i hope we progress
to a place where we're we are a true
equality happens where we're fine with
all that
because i think we start to tiff and
fight over those little things because
we're not
experiencing equality in our day to day
and if we were then we would care
way less about that kind of stuff that
is very very well said
i mean yes i mean that is 100 agree with
that
the other thing is like uh i learned
this from touring with like you
jack and and chris is like yes
uh do you think it'd be positive if
comedian
white comedians stepped down from doing
a black scent
on stage i just think it's dumb and
hacky so
like just don't just don't do it because
it's stupid anyone not familiar a white
comedian
who looks just like me would be like
yeah man y'all already
know this [ __ ] what are you doing
what and i mean yeah just don't do that
we were in
i think it was san diego and you were
just like no from the back of the room
just don't do that that might actually
be helpful
indeed this is really great talking to
you i mean this was fun
i really trust you i trust people that
have called me a [ __ ] to my face
right i remember once ever at jack's
taping i was wearing a quilted
dress shirt uh one of the many mistakes
i've made and you're like moses you're
such a [ __ ] wearing a
quilted dress shirt so i respect you
ever since then and love you more than
anything so thank you so much for
doing this you know donna's daughter is
a is a
album you already have out and then
newly three in the morning is on netflix
right now sam j thank you so much
thanks bye